From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International.
来自芝加哥WBEZ，这里是《美国生活》，由公共广播国际台发行。
I have a relative that's my aunt. She doesn't really know how to talk to kids. She's sort of--
我有个亲戚是我阿姨。她不太懂得怎么跟孩子沟通。她有点……
My grandma. She doesn't know what to say to me. She's trying to talk to me, but usually she doesn't know what to say.
我奶奶。她不知道该对我说什么。她试图和我谈话，但通常她不知道该说什么。
The people on my dad's side, they don't know how to talk to kids. They go, oh, you're so cute. They have got to say like, oh, he's so cute--
我爸爸那边的亲戚，他们不知道怎么跟孩子交谈。他们只会说，哦，你真可爱。他们非得说，哦，他真可爱——
Oh, you're so cute.
哦，你真可爱。
--like you were born yesterday.
——就好像你才刚出生一样。
Not me only, but a lot of other kids don't like to be talked down to like they're three years old.
不仅是我，很多其他孩子也不喜欢被当作三岁小孩那样居高临下地对待。
Sometimes when they speak to children, their voice changes into this kind of voice where they're talking to two year olds.
有时候他们跟孩子说话时，声音会变调，变成那种跟两岁小孩说话的语气。
It's like they're talking to you with baby talk.
就好像他们在用儿语跟你说话。
Yeah. They still think I'm a five year old.
是的。他们还以为我只有五岁。
Fellow adults, if you have ever had the experience of hanging around with a kid and not knowing what to say, and you told yourself, well, whatever, they're just a child. They're so different from us. They won't really notice. Turns out? Wrong.
各位成年人，如果你们曾经有过和孩子待在一起却不知道说什么的经历，并且安慰自己说，“好吧，管他呢，他们只是个孩子。他们和我们太不一样了，他们不会注意到的。”结果呢？错了。
She says, how's school? What's going on? She tries to understand--
她说，学校怎么样？最近怎么样？她试图去理解——
So, how was school?
那么，学校怎么样？
How was school is the typical adult question. So you have to answer it like 6,000 times a year. So if they say, how is school, you know they have nothing else to say, or they don't know what to say.
“学校怎么样”是典型的成年人问题。所以你一年得回答六千次。所以如果他们问学校怎么样，你就知道他们没什么别的话可说，或者他们根本不知道该说什么。
So, how is school? All adults do that, no matter what. Some adults are worse than others, but--
所以，学校怎么样？所有大人都这样，不管怎样。有些大人比别人更糟糕，但是——
Adults should know by now, kids don't really like talking about school. It's always like, what did you do? And the kid says, nothing. Or they'll say something like, we had math today.
大人们现在应该知道了，孩子们其实不喜欢谈论学校。总是问，你做了什么？孩子回答说，没什么。或者他们会说，我们今天上了数学课。
Yeah, with my parents, I just go, can you ask more specific? When it's just like that, and I just want to get out of it, I just go, oh, it's been really nice. Yeah, I like science the best. Assuming their next question, and then getting out of it.
是啊，面对我父母，我只会说，你们能问得具体点吗？当他们那样问，而我只想逃避时，我就会说，哦，挺好的。是的，我最喜欢科学课。假设他们会问下一个问题，然后赶紧避开。
If you want to talk to kids, kids say, talk about stuff that interests you and them, like you would with anybody. Also, not so much teasing all the time. Also, don't repeat the same things to them every time you see them.
如果你想跟孩子交流，孩子们会说，谈论你和他们都感兴趣的事情，就像对待其他人一样。另外，别总是不停地取笑他们。还有，别每次见面都重复同样的话。
My parents, they're always asking, so, who do you have a crush on?
我父母总是问，那么，你有暗恋的对象吗？
Mine too! Mine too.
我也是！我也是。
Well, I have a neighbor that kind of teases me. He's pretty old. He always says like, you're a mama's boy and, who's your girlfriend? Well, it just doesn't feel right.
嗯，有个邻居老爱取笑我。他年纪挺大了。他总是说，你是个妈宝，谁是你女朋友？这感觉真不好。
Also, sometimes they make a joke when you're seven, and you laugh so much at it. And then, when you're 10 or 11, it's not so funny anymore. And they keep saying the joke. And you just go, oh, that's not very funny anymore.
还有，有时候他们会在你七岁时开个玩笑，你当时笑得不行。然后，当你十岁或十一岁时，那个玩笑就不那么好笑了。但他们还一直说那个笑话。你就只能说，哦，那已经不好笑了。
Can you think of an example like that?
你能想到类似的例子吗？
My dad, he's the kind of guy who makes those jokes all the time. And he's like-- I asked him now, can you make me a sandwich? He's like, poof! Aw, didn't work. And that really annoys me. He does that all the time in front of my friends. And it kind of annoys me sometimes.
我爸，他就是那种老开这种玩笑的人。他就像……我现在问他，能帮我做个三明治吗？他会说，呼！哎呀，没变出来。这真的很烦人。他总是在我朋友面前这样做。有时候真的很让我恼火。
Now was that funny when you were five?
那当你五岁时这好笑吗？
Yeah. It was funny like the first couple of times.
是的。前几次还是挺好笑的。
Honestly, when his dad goes like, poof, sandwich! Aw, didn't work, honestly, I find that really funny, sometimes.
老实说，当他爸说，呼，三明治！哎呀，没变出来，老实说，我有时候觉得挺好笑的。
You're not around him all the time. And it gets repetitive. And it's not that funny anymore.
你又不总是和他在一起。这变得很重复。而且已经没那么好笑了。
Now are you saying that people should talk to you guys like you're adults exactly? Or is there a difference?
你是说人们应该完全把你们当作成年人来对待吗？还是说有什么区别？
Not like adults, but just like, not three year olds. Just ten year olds, which we are.
不是像对待大人，只是，别像对待三岁小孩那样。就把我们当作十岁小孩，我们确实是十岁。
Of course for the kids it's totally obvious the difference between a three year old and a ten year old, and a fifteen year old, and whatever. But for adults, that is exactly what is so delicate. You don't want to talk down, but you also don't want to be unclear. You want to relate and be fun, but you also are the adult and you have to be the voice of responsibility, and sometimes, actually, discipline. And so today we bring you stories of people who have struggled to do this well, taking very different approaches, in some very tough situations. Some real stumpers, actually. Situations where most of us would have a hard time figuring out what to say.
当然，对孩子来说，三岁、十岁、十五岁之间的区别显而易见。但对成年人来说，这正是最微妙的地方。你既不想居高临下，又不想表达不清。你想亲近且有趣，但你同时又是成年人，必须成为负责任的代言人，有时甚至不得不去管教。所以今天我们带来了一些人在处理这种关系时挣扎的故事，他们采取了截然不同的方式，处境也很艰难。甚至是一些真正让人犯难的情况，大多数人在这些情况下都会不知道该说什么。
Our show today in three acts. Act One, So, Kids: A Priest, a Rabbi, and a Hooker Walk into a Bar. In that act, two men get a job where they have to make jokes for kids, though they actually don't have any special understanding of kids at all. Act Two, Age of Consent. You know, you tell your kids, come to me, tell me anything. So what do you do then when they take you up on it, and say things to you that you have no idea how to respond to? Act Three, Use Your Words. In that act, Dan Savage makes the case for yelling at children. No kidding. Not just yelling, but trying to scare them with your yelling. Stay with us.
今天的节目分为三幕。第一幕，关于孩子们：一位牧师、一位拉比和一个妓女走进酒吧。在这一幕中，两个男人得到一份工作，负责给孩子讲笑话，尽管他们对孩子根本没有任何了解。第二幕，同意的年龄。你知道，你告诉孩子，来找我，什么都可以跟我说。那么当他们真的找你，对你说出你完全不知道如何回应的话时，你该怎么办？第三幕，用你的语言。在这一幕中，丹·萨维奇（Dan Savage）提出了对孩子大吼大叫的理由。没开玩笑。不仅是大吼，还要试图用大吼来吓唬他们。请继续收听。
Act One. Sean O'Connor and Nick Maritato have jobs that keep them about as far away from talking to kids as anybody could be. They're professional comedians. Young ones, just starting out. Their job is basically to say stuff that kids shouldn't hear. Until this summer. They got hired to perform at summer camps, six summer camps. Average age of the audience? 11. One of the producers of our show, Jane Feltes, tells what happened.
第一幕。肖恩·奥康纳（Sean O'Connor）和尼克·马里塔托（Nick Maritato）所做的工作让他们几乎远离任何与孩子打交道的机会。他们是职业喜剧演员。还是刚起步的年轻人。他们的工作基本上就是讲些孩子不该听的话。直到今年夏天。他们被雇佣在夏令营表演，一共六个夏令营。观众的平均年龄？11岁。我们节目的一位制片人简·费尔特斯（Jane Feltes）讲述了发生的事情。
Sean usually gets to work around 9:00 or 10:00 at night. He often performs at a bar called Rififi, in the East Village in New York City. Everyone here is in their 20s, drinking, and talking about where they're going to drink later. You know, adult stuff.
肖恩通常在晚上9点或10点左右开始工作。他经常在纽约东村一家叫Rififi的酒吧表演。这里的人都在20多岁，喝着酒，讨论着待会要去哪儿喝。你知道的，成人的消遣。
I just got kicked out of college. And I called my friend up. And I was like, hey, Jimmy, what are you doing tonight? And he's like, oh man, I just bet Steve that I could do heroin and not get addicted to it.
我刚被大学开除。我打电话给我朋友。我说，嘿，吉米，你今晚干嘛呢？他说，哦伙计，我刚跟史蒂夫打赌，说我可以吸海洛因但不会上瘾。
Sean is 22, and he's hilarious. He has a small following. Sometimes he headlines. His audience loves him. He's kind of like a younger, blonder, cuddlier Jack Black. His material is about doing drugs, and being lazy, and getting in trouble in high school, and being mistaken for gay. So who would ask this guy to make jokes for kids at summer camp? Rachel Tipograph. And she has a lot of experience.
肖恩22岁，非常风趣。他有一小群拥趸。有时他会压轴出场。观众很喜欢他。他有点像年轻、金发、更讨喜的杰克·布莱克。他的素材是关于吸毒、懒惰、在高中惹麻烦以及被误认为同性恋。那么谁会请这家伙去夏令营给孩子讲笑话呢？蕾切尔·蒂波格拉夫（Rachel Tipograph）。她很有经验。
I went to camp. I went to day camp. And then I went seven years sleep away camp in Maine. And I was a counselor at camp last summer.
我去过夏令营。我去过日间营。然后我在缅因州参加了七年的住宿夏令营。去年夏天我还当了营地辅导员。
Rachel is in college, and she's a super ambitious 20 year old. She has business cards and letterhead. This summer, drawing on her eight years of camp experience, Rachel came up with an idea. Camps hire local entertainers, who Rachel thinks could be more entertaining.
蕾切尔还在上大学，是个雄心勃勃的20岁姑娘。她有自己的名片和信笺。今年夏天，借鉴她八年的营地经验，蕾切尔想出了一个主意。营地通常会聘请当地艺人，但蕾切尔觉得他们可以更有趣。
A lot of times, you'll see a magician. And he's been there for 15 years. And he's getting very old. And he has his son helping him. Or you'll see a local DJ, you know, ex-hippie, knows all about Woodstock, he was there. So I was like, you know what? Entertainment doesn't have to be corny. It doesn't have to be crappy. These camps are in travelable distance from New York City. The New York City comedy world's great, but it's not lucrative. So why not send these young comedians, who are very flexible, out to the camps?
很多时候，你会看到一个魔术师。他在那里待了15年了。他已经很老了。还有他儿子帮忙。或者你会看到一个当地的DJ，你知道的，老嬉皮士，知道关于伍德斯托克的一切，他当时就在现场。所以我想，你知道吗？娱乐表演不必非得俗气。不必非得蹩脚。这些营地距离纽约市不远。纽约的喜剧圈很棒，但不赚钱。那为什么不把这些非常灵活的年轻喜剧演员派去营地呢？
So she set up this business and started to recruit comedians. Which led her to Nick and Sean. But it wasn't an easy sell. Here's Nick.
于是她创办了这个业务，开始招募喜剧演员。这让她找到了尼克和肖恩。但这并不容易推销。这是尼克说的。
When Sean asked me to do this, he asked me via text message. He was like, hey, do you want to do comedy for camps this summer? And I said, no, exclamation point. And then I was like, uh, we're getting paid for that, right?
当肖恩问我要不要做这个时，他是发短信问的。他说，嘿，这个夏天你想去营地讲喜剧吗？我说，不，加个感叹号。然后我就说，呃，我们有报酬吧？
This is Sean.
这是肖恩。
She was like, there's a ton of money involved. And I was like, awesome! Perfect! Say no more. This is great.
她说，报酬相当丰厚。然后我说，太棒了！完美！别说了。这太好了。
Did your eyes turn into dollar signs?
你的眼睛变成美元符号了吗？
It did, it did. And I opened my mouth, and just went cha-ching. It was weird. My head was a cash register.
变了，变了。我张开嘴，就发出“叮当”的声音。很奇怪。我的脑袋成了一个收银机。
The ton of money that turns a struggling comedian's head into a cash register might not be as much as you think. Nick and Sean usually don't even get paid. In fact, they told me that a lot of the time, they have to pay to get on stage. Or do what's called a bringer-- bring their own audience. And that gets old fast for the handful of friends who are willing to go.
这笔让窘迫的喜剧演员脑袋变成收银机的“丰厚报酬”可能没你想的那么多。尼克和肖恩平时甚至拿不到报酬。事实上，他们告诉我很多时候还得花钱才能上台。或者做所谓的“自带观众”——带自己的粉丝来。这对那些愿意捧场的寥寥几个朋友来说，很快就会感到厌倦。
Rachel, on the other hand, was offering $500 a show. And they were doing six shows. A ton of money to these guys. But they were going to have to work for it.
另一方面，蕾切尔每场表演提供500美元。他们要演六场。对这几个家伙来说是一大笔钱。但他们得努力挣这笔钱。
Boom! Falling off a couch. Falling into a couch. Falling next to a couch.
砰！从沙发上掉下来。掉进沙发里。掉在沙发旁边。
To write all new, kid friendly comedy, the guys spent hours in the living room, watching Nickelodeon, looking for pointers.
为了创作全新的、适合儿童的喜剧，这几个人在客厅里花了几小时看尼克国际儿童频道，寻找灵感。
Nothing better on a peanut butter sandwich than pickled chips, a little bit of mustard.
花生酱三明治上没比腌黄瓜片和一点点芥末更好的了。
Foods like chili, and mustard, and pickles? Hilarious.
像辣椒、芥末和腌黄瓜这样的食物？太搞笑了。
Stand up comedy is all about relating to an audience. Talking really frankly about the things we all experience, and then adding some funny observation that we wish we thought of. That's why so many jokes start with, so you know when you're at the DMV? Or, the thing about working in an office is. But these kids are 11. Nick told me they thought about producing some tutorial videos that would give the campers the essential background information they needed, in order to understand his jokes.
脱口秀的关键在于与观众产生共鸣。坦诚地谈论我们都有的经历，然后加上一些我们希望自己能想到的有趣观察。这就是为什么很多笑话开头都是，“你知道当你去车管所的时候吗？”或者，“在办公室工作的特点是……”。但这些孩子才11岁。尼克告诉我，他们考虑过制作一些指导视频，为营员提供必要的背景信息，这样他们才能听懂笑话。
We had this idea. We were like, it would be funny if we--
我们当时有个主意。我们觉得，如果我们能这样……
Like, tell a joke, and it would be about sex. And then cut to, OK, when a man loves a woman-- like have to explain life to them before.
比如，讲个笑话，是关于性的。然后切镜头说，好的，当一个男人爱上一个女人……就像必须提前给他们解释人生。
And a long time ago, white people thought it was OK to own black people. They used a very dirty word called the n-word. And we're not going to use it right now. Do kids at this age know they're going to die yet? No?
很久以前，白人认为拥有黑人是可以的。他们用了一个非常肮脏的词，叫N开头的那个词。我们现在不用它。这个年纪的孩子知道他们会死吗？不知道吗？
[PHONE DIALIING AND RINGING]
[电话拨号和响铃声]
Hey, Rachel.
嘿，蕾切尔。
How are you?
你好吗？
I'm good, how are you?
我很好，你呢？
To top it all off, Rachel gave them a list of things they're absolutely not allowed to joke about. No sex, drugs, alcohol, getting in trouble, no ethnic jokes, no making fun of kids, no making fun of parents, no making fun of camp counselors, no hurting anyone's feelings, which really doesn't leave the guys much to work with. And they call Rachel now and then to run ideas by her.
最重要的是，蕾切尔给了他们一份清单，列出绝对不能开玩笑的事情。不能有性、毒品、酒精，不能讲惹麻烦的事，不能开民族笑话，不能取笑孩子，不能取笑家长，不能取笑营地辅导员，不能伤害任何人的感情，这确实没给他们留下多少素材。他们现在还会时不时给蕾切尔打电话过一下想法。
We just were wondering about like I have this joke about how I got gay-bashed. Can I talk about that?
我们只是在想，我有个关于我因为是同性恋而遭到袭击的笑话。我可以讲这个吗？
No. If you guys started doing that, I can honestly see a camp woman getting on stage, and kicking you guys off.
不行。如果你们开始讲那个，我老实说，我能看到营地里的女性走上台，把你们轰下来。
Whoa. I wouldn't want that. I don't want that.
哇。我可不想那样。我不想那样。
Yeah, I don't want that either.
是的，我也不想。
Can we make fat jokes, like about us?
那我们可以开肥胖的玩笑吗？比如开我们自己的？
Um. If you honestly think like, oh, well this joke might get me in trouble, I wouldn't do it.
嗯。如果你真心觉得，哦，这个笑话可能会让我惹麻烦，那我就不会讲它。
OK.
好的。
OK, thanks Rachel.
好的，谢谢你蕾切尔。
OK. Thank you.
好的。谢谢。
All right. Bye.
好的。再见。
Bye.
再见。
They tried adapting some of their regular material, like a joke Sean had about having a party when your parents are out of town, and getting drunk and destroying stuff. Only without the party, or the drinking, or the destruction.
他们试着改编了一些常规素材，比如肖恩有个笑话，讲的是父母不在家时开派对，喝得烂醉，破坏东西。只是把派对、喝酒和破坏都去掉了。
A few days before the first show, Rachel asked Nick and Sean to send over a script of their entire routine, just so she could be absolutely sure they were on schedule and being kid appropriate. And she approved almost all it. Which sounded promising. Until I asked Sean to try out some of the material on me.
第一场演出前几天，蕾切尔让尼克和肖恩发去整套剧本，好确定他们安排合理且适合孩子。她几乎批准了所有内容。听起来很有希望。直到我让肖恩试着给我讲讲这些素材。
Yeah. Oh, man. They're so bad. I love soup because not only is it delicious, it's also an awesome weapon.
好的。天哪。烂透了。我喜欢汤，不仅因为它美味，还因为它是一种很棒的武器。
I don't get it.
我没听懂。
It's hot. Because soups hot. If you throw it at someone, it hurts. What if I said hot soup?
它很烫。因为汤很烫。如果你扔向某人，会很痛。如果我说“热汤”呢？
It's a three hour drive north to Camp Taconic in Massachusetts. And on the way up, the guys are singing along to music, and stopping for donuts, and doing impressions of Rachel. But the mood turns as we get closer to camp.
去马萨诸塞州的塔科尼克营地要开三个小时的车。在路上，几个人跟着音乐唱歌，停车买甜甜圈，模仿蕾切尔。但随着接近营地，心情变得沉重。
Oh, my Lord. It's a real camp.
天哪。真是个营地。
The first thing we see when we pull up to Camp Taconic are rows of cute little cabins. There's a pond, and a barn, and a tether ball, and kids scattered about.
我们到达塔科尼克营地时看到的第一样东西是一排排可爱的小木屋。有一个池塘，一个谷仓，一个绳球，到处都是孩子。
I quit. See you later.
我不干了。待会见。
I'm done. We're done. This is over. Interview done.
我完了。我们完了。一切结束了。采访结束了。
Oh, my God. This is so weird. And scary. I have so many different feelings right now.
天哪。太奇怪了。而且很吓人。我现在心里有各种感觉。
Like?
比如？
Fear. Nervousness. Getting bitten by bugs, is that a feeling?
恐惧。紧张。被虫子咬，那算感觉吗？
The show is being held in a little lodge. And there are long wooden benches full of fidgety kids wrapped in blankets. A few hundred of them. They look so tiny. You can tell they're really excited. I overhear one boy asking his friends, "Do you think these guys know Dane Cook?" Who is pretty much the favorite stand-up among preteens right now.
演出在一个小屋里举行。长长的木凳上挤满了裹着毯子、动来动去的小孩。有几百个。他们看起来真小。你能看出他们非常兴奋。我听到一个男孩问朋友：“你们觉得这两个家伙认识戴恩·库克（Dane Cook）吗？”他几乎是目前学龄前儿童中最受欢迎的脱口秀演员。
Counselors get their kids to quiet down, and Nick and Sean walk to the mic. They have been planning this moment for weeks, writing, and rewriting, and guessing about how the kids would react. And now, here they were.
辅导员让孩子们安静下来，尼克和肖恩走向麦克风。他们为了这一刻策划了数周，写作、改写，猜测孩子们的反应。现在，他们站在这里。
The longer it takes for you to be quiet, the longer it takes for us to start. Thank you very much.
你们安静得越慢，我们就开始得越慢。非常感谢。
The first thing that you could do is introduce what we are going to do first, for this friggin' awesome thing.
你们首先能做的事，就是介绍我们要为这件该死的棒事做些什么。
Friggin'. He said friggin'. Kids look at each other like, what did he almost say? It just throws everybody, Sean and Nick included.
该死的。他说该死了。孩子们面面相觑，心想，他刚才差点要说什么？这让所有人都感到尴尬，包括肖恩和尼克。
Um. What are we going to do?
嗯。我们要做什么？
It goes steadily downhill from there. Jokes don't land. And some jokes, they're like not even jokes.
之后情况越来越糟。笑话没包袱。有的笑话甚至根本算不上笑话。
Here's another reason why I didn't want to go to sleep away camp. You have got to sleep in bunks. And that weirds me out. Because bunks are 100% made of wood, right? And you know what I am really afraid of is fire. And wood is the easiest thing to set on fire. I don't want to be set on fire when I'm sleeping. I mean, who does, right?
这是我不想去住宿夏令营的另一个原因。你得睡铺位。这让我觉得很怪。因为铺位100%是木头做的，对吧？你知道我真的很怕火。而木头是最容易着火的东西。我可不想在睡觉时被烧死。我是说，谁会想呢，对吧？
What? What is he even talking about?
什么？他到底在说什么？
We live in wood bunks, you know.
我们住在木头铺位里，你知道的。
I know. Has anybody tried to set you guys on fire before?
我知道。有人试过把你们点着吗？
The counselors' faces say it all. They're horrified. They're even giving me dirty looks. And then, there are hecklers. Four boys sitting on the floor in front of Sean who are talking to him through his entire act. I mean they will not shut up.
辅导员们的脸说明了一切。他们感到恐惧。甚至对我投来厌恶的目光。然后，有捣乱的。肖恩前面地上坐着四个男孩，一直在他表演时说话。我是说他们根本不停。
I think-- you guys know Applebee's? You love Applebee's? It's your grandparents' favorite restaurant?
我觉得……你们知道苹果蜂餐厅吗？你们喜欢苹果蜂吗？那是你们祖父母最喜欢的餐厅吗？
Yeah, it's my grandparents' favorite restaurant.
是的，那是我祖父母最喜欢的餐厅。
Great. I love you. You just keep talking. It's awesome. Because that's what I wanted. I wanted to come up here and just talk to-- what's your name?
太棒了。我爱你。你就一直说吧。太好了。因为这正是我想的。我想上来这里，只是和……你叫什么名字？
Daniel.
丹尼尔。
Daniel? Awesome. You guys are so good. Come up here.
丹尼尔？太棒了。你们真行。上来吧。
Four little boys jump up, totally excited and grinning. It's clear to everyone in the room that in the battle between adults and children, the children had suddenly got the upper hand. It's Lord of the Flies up in here. Sean's losing control.
四个小男孩跳起来，满脸兴奋，咧着嘴笑。房间里的每个人都清楚，在成人与儿童的较量中，孩子突然占了上风。这简直就是《蝇王》。肖恩正在失去控制。
OK. Since you guys just love attention and stuff, you guys can all each tell a joke. And if they don't laugh, you have to go sit down and not talk.
好的。既然你们这么喜欢受关注之类的，你们每个人都可以讲个笑话。如果他们不笑，你就得坐下，闭嘴。
All right. OK, I'll go first.
好的。行，我先来。
You go first!
你先来！
So there are two Irish guys in a pub.
有两个爱尔兰人在酒吧里。
OK! [LAUGHTER] We're good! No, you win!
好了！[笑声] 我们够了！不，你赢了！
Ethnic joke? Check. Drinking joke? Check. He was right to cut him off. And this speaks to the whole problem here. Sean and Nick are telling kids jokes to kids who already know adult jokes and find them funny. After all, Dane Cook is their favorite comedian. And he's crazy dirty.
民族笑话？确认。酗酒笑话？确认。他及时打断是对的。这反映了这里整体的问题。肖恩和尼克在给一群本就听得懂成人笑话且觉得那很有趣的孩子讲冷笑话。毕竟，戴恩·库克是他们最喜欢的喜剧演员。而且他满口脏话。
At one point, the guys just give up. The kids are talking, not laughing, not paying attention. But Sean and Nick can't end the show yet, because it's a camp. And every hour is planned. The kids have to stay in this building, sitting down, fidgeting until bedtime. So Sean and Nick stop being comedians. They just do anything they can think of to keep the crowd occupied.
有那么一刻，这俩人彻底放弃了。孩子们在说话，不笑，不注意听。但肖恩和尼克还不能结束演出，因为这是夏令营。每小时都有计划。孩子们必须待在楼里，坐着，不安分地等到睡觉时间。所以肖恩和尼克不再做喜剧演员了。他们只是想方设法让观众保持忙碌。
I mean it's like, how bad do you guys just want to scream at the top of your lungs?
我是说，你们有多想扯开嗓子尖叫？
I want to scream! AHHHHHH!
我想尖叫！啊！！
[SCREAMING]
[尖叫声]
Good! Good! Good!
好！好！好！
Finally it's over. And the kids rush back to their bunks. No signing of autographs, no high fives. I talked to a few of them about what we just saw.
终于结束了。孩子们冲回宿舍。没有签名，没有击掌。我和其中几个人聊了聊刚才的演出。
They're definitely not comedians.
他们绝对不是喜剧演员。
Do you have any advice for next time?
下次你们有什么建议吗？
They could make the jokes a little more mature and things.
他们可以把笑话讲得更成熟一点之类的。
Be funnier.
表现得更有趣点。
Yeah, exactly. Get better at it. Practice at it.
是的，确实。表现得更好一点。多练习。
Read some joke books.
多读些笑话书。
Exactly.
确实。
I find a group of staff people standing outside the lodge. There are six grown people standing here in a circle. Six of them, hands in their pockets, kicking the dirt.
我发现一群工作人员站在小屋外面。六个成年人站在那里围成一圈。六个人，手插在兜里，踢着泥土。
Do you think the kids liked it? Did you guys like it? Anyone?
你觉得孩子们喜欢吗？你们喜欢吗？有人喜欢吗？
I thought it was a little inappropriate. Talk about death and burning bunks. Adults maybe can handle it. But these are kids. So I thought it was a little inappropriate.
我觉得有点不合适。谈论死亡和烧毁铺位。成年人可能受得了。但这些是孩子。所以我认为有点不合适。
On the way home, the guys talked about how it wasn't that bad, and about stuff that had nothing to do with the performance at all. I kept my thoughts to myself. A week later, we finally sat down together. You know, I think part of being a performer is living in denial about failing. You don't want to decide you're the comedian who bombs, because then how hard would it be to go on stage next time?
回家的路上，这两人谈论着其实没那么糟，还有其他与表演无关的事情。我把想法藏在心里。一周后，我们终于坐在一起。你知道，我觉得作为表演者，生活在失败的否定中是必然的。你不想认为自己是那个砸场的喜剧演员，因为那样的话，下次上台该有多难？
How do you think it went?
你觉得进展如何？
The shows, they went well. A lot better than I thought they were going to go. They didn't-- I don't think that it was amazing.
演出，进展顺利。比我想象的好多了。没……我不觉得那有多精彩。
And you Sean?
你呢，肖恩？
I thought the shows were awesome. What did they think?
我觉得演出太棒了。他们怎么看？
All right. Well, they all hated it.
好吧。嗯，他们都讨厌透了。
Now, when you say they, do you mean all?
那么，当你说他们时，是指所有人吗？
They all hated it.
他们全讨厌死了。
What did they say?
他们说了什么？
were scary.
很吓人。
Yeah, you know what? That's pretty right on.
是啊，你知道吗？这评价挺到位的。
The counselors thought that it was totally inappropriate. They said you were unprepared. A couple of girls told me that their counselor felt so bad that they had to sit through it, that they got to stay up really late out in the field playing games, so that they could have had something fun to do that night.
辅导员们认为这完全不合时宜。他们说你们没准备好。有几个女孩告诉我，她们的辅导员觉得必须忍受这个演出简直太糟糕了，所以让她们在外面草地上玩游戏玩到很晚，好让她们那晚能有点乐子。
I agree. I felt it. I went out there. I looked at them. They were just confused. They didn't like it.
我同意。我感受到了。我走出去。我看着他们。他们只是感到困惑。他们不喜欢。
Of course, this is just the opposite of what he said when I first asked him just a minute before, which he cops to right away.
当然，这和他刚才问我时说的话完全相反，他立刻承认了。
Why would I really think that was good? I was literally going through the motions. But if outright you have clips of people saying that it's terrible and things like-- OK, I'm not going to hide it. I'm not a moron. That was bad. I didn't have a fun time. I was so happy when it was over.
我为什么会真的觉得那很好？我简直是照本宣科。但如果你直接有视频说那是灾难……好的，我不躲了。我又不是傻瓜。那很糟糕。我一点也不开心。结束时我太高兴了。
Honestly, when I got home on Monday, it felt so weird, because it felt like a part of me was missing. I'm not even kidding when I say this. So don't roll your eyes. I got so stressed out, I just felt like it was like my whole world came crashing down.
老实说，周一回到家时，感觉太怪了，因为感觉我的一部分丢了。我没开玩笑。别翻白眼。我太紧张了，感觉整个世界都在崩塌。
I went home to my parents' house, because I had my dad's car from that trip. And when I dropped it off, I just went upstairs to my room and laid in my bed. And I woke up at 1:00 AM. And I felt so disoriented. What happened was my heart started racing.
我回到父母家，因为那次旅行开了我爸的车。送回去后，我上楼回房间躺在床上。我在凌晨1点醒来。我感到非常迷茫。心跳加速。
Sean said he started to breathe faster. And he was sweating. And then suddenly, he felt a pain when he tried to swallow. And it just wouldn't go away. After a few minutes, he had convinced himself that he had throat cancer and was about to die.
肖恩说他的呼吸变快了。他在冒汗。突然，他尝试吞咽时感到疼痛。而且痛感一直不消。几分钟后，他确信自己患了喉癌，快要死了。
And I Googled throat cancer. And of course, when you Google something you have all the symptoms, because you could have all those symptoms and have anything. But they're the same symptoms as a cold. So I Googled that. And I was like, oh, I do have throat cancer. So I actually woke my parents up. I was like, take me to the hospital.
我谷歌了喉癌。当然，当你谷歌某些东西时，你会觉得自己有所有症状，因为你可能有这些症状中的任何一种。但它们和感冒的症状一样。所以我谷歌了那个。我心想，哦，我确实得了喉癌。所以我真的叫醒了父母。我说，带我去医院。
That was the first of four trips to the ER. He had blood work done, and CAT scans, and a barium swallow, and various other tests. All of which came back negative. No cancer. No nothing. Turned out he was having panic attacks and was told to start seeing someone about his anxiety.
那是他四次去急诊的第一回。他做了验血、CT扫描、钡餐吞咽检查，还有其他各种测试。结果全部为阴性。没癌症。什么事都没有。结果他是在惊恐发作，并被告知要去看心理医生治疗焦虑。
Well my whole thing was I didn't want to bomb. Not having people like me. That's pretty much-- that was where all the stress was coming. When I do comedy, when everyone does comedy, if you don't find the jokes funny, it's really hard to say them with conviction. There's no way to sell jokes that you don't find funny.
我的症结在于我不想砸场。不想让人讨厌。那是……所有的压力都来源于此。做喜剧时，如果观众不觉得好笑，真的很难有信心地把笑话讲出来。没有办法兜售你自己都觉得不好笑的笑话。
You guys forgot that you were funny.
你们忘了自己本来是有趣的。
Yeah, that's really what it was. Everyone was just going like, just be funny, be funny. And then you're like, I have got to be funny. But if you just are funny, it's better than trying. Trying to be funny is the worst. You could smell that from a mile away, the desperation of needing laughter.
是的，就是这样。每个人都说，搞笑点，搞笑点。然后你就心想，我必须搞笑。但如果你只是搞笑，比刻意尝试要好。刻意尝试搞笑是最差劲的，那种对笑声的需求，隔着一英里都能闻到那股绝望的气味。
In a way, they were doomed from the start. Like I said, Sean is 22, Nick is 20. And this is the worst possible age to connect with an 11 year old. When you're 22, you don't want to remember what it was like to be 11. You're frantically running away from that. No wonder they couldn't be funny for kids.
某种程度上，他们从一开始就注定了失败。正如我所说，肖恩22岁，尼克20岁。这是与11岁孩子产生共鸣的最糟糕年纪。当你22岁时，你根本不想回忆11岁是什么样子。你在拼命逃离那段时光。难怪他们没法给孩子带来快乐。
The guys did five other camp shows. And they swear-- for real, for real this time-- that they got better. For one thing, they weren't as nervous. Believe it or not, they're going out again next summer.
那几个人还演了五场营地演出。他们发誓——这次是真的，是真的——他们做得更好了。首先，他们没那么紧张了。信不信由你，他们明年夏天还要去。
Jane Feltes.
简·费尔特斯。
[MUSIC - "KIDS DON'T FOLLOW" BY THE REPLACEMENTS]
[音乐 - The Replacements的《Kids Don't Follow》]
Coming up, kids talk about sex. Dan Savage doesn't. Incredible. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，孩子们谈论性。丹·萨维奇则不谈。不可思议。片刻之后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际台，节目继续。
Chelsea is 18. And because she sees some problems with the way that many adults talk to kids about sex, she became one of the editors of a magazine where teenagers write about sex for a teenage audience. It's called Sex, Etc. And of course they have a website, though be careful how you type in the address.
切尔西18岁。因为她看到许多成年人在与孩子讨论性话题时存在问题，她成为了一本杂志的编辑之一，青少年们在杂志上为同龄人写关于性的文章。它叫《Sex, Etc.》。当然他们有网站，不过输入地址时要小心。
Sexetc.com actually is porn. But sexetc.org, that's our site.
Sexetc.com其实是色情网站。但Sexetc.org才是我们的网站。
That's Karen, another teen editor. I talked to seven of them. There is also [? Sharonia ?], Natasha, Michael, Erica, and Ethan. All but two of them are seniors in high school, 17 years old. In the magazine they write very chatty and very frank articles about say, boys saying no to sex, about the availability of abortion for teenagers, about misperceptions about HIV, and condoms, and how you get pregnant.
那是凯伦，另一位少年编辑。我和他们七个人谈过。还有莎罗尼亚、娜塔莎、迈克尔、埃里卡和伊桑。除了两个，他们都是高中三年级学生，17岁。在杂志里，他们写了非常健谈且坦诚的文章，谈论比如男孩拒绝性行为、青少年堕胎的途径、关于艾滋病毒和避孕套的错误观念，以及你是如何怀孕的。
I visited them because they seemed like the perfect people to discuss how adults talk about sex with kids. For one thing, they had done a survey of their readers on this very subject.
我拜访他们是因为他们似乎是讨论成年人如何与孩子谈性话题的完美人选。首先，他们针对读者做了一项关于这个主题的调查。
Actually the first time sex ever came up between me and my parents--
其实我和父母第一次谈及性时……
A warning to listeners, we don't get very explicit in this discussion, but we do acknowledge that people, and teenagers, have sex.
给听众的警告，我们在这次讨论中不会非常露骨，但我们承认人们和青少年会有性行为。
--what happened was, it was when Friends , that TV sitcom, was like really big. So my parents used to watch it all the time. And they used to have a lot of sex jokes on that show. So one day, during a commercial break, I turned to my dad-- which I picked the wrong parent, by the way. I should have really just asked my mother. I asked my dad, what is sex? And he had no idea what to tell me for a second.
发生的事情是，当时《老友记》那部电视情景喜剧非常火。我父母总是看。那节目里有很多性笑话。所以有一天，广告插播期间，我转向我爸——顺便说一下，我找错了家长。我真该去问我妈。我问我爸，什么是性？他有一秒钟不知道该告诉我什么。
So he turned off the TV, he looked at me, and he said, "It's when grown adults want to, like, hold each other and hug each other." I mean, that was such a terrible explanation. I was so unsatisfied with what he told me.
于是他关掉电视，看着我，说：“就是成年人想要……比如拥抱在一起。”我的意思是，那是个太烂的解释了。我对他的回答非常不满意。
In their survey, lots of kids complained about vagueness and lack of useful information. One kid wrote, "My first conversation with my mom about sex was really weird. It was almost like she was preaching to me how if I have sex, I will have a baby, and then die. It was the night before my sixth grade dance." Another wrote, "My dad started the conversation. He took me out in the backyard when the orange tree was pollinating, and explained how it worked." One student wrote that her mom ambushed her in the car. "The first time you have sex is not going to be fun," was her first warning. "It's awkward, it's embarrassing-- and trust me on this-- it's going to hurt." Well thanks, Mom.
在他们的调查中，很多孩子抱怨模糊和缺乏有用信息。一个孩子写道：“我妈跟我进行第一次关于性的谈话时真是太怪了。几乎就像她在向我布道，如果我发生性关系，就会怀孕，然后死去。那是六年纪舞会的前一天晚上。”另一个写道：“是我爸发起的谈话。他带我到后院，当时橘子树正在传粉，他就解释了它是如何运作的。”一名学生写道，她妈在车里突袭了她。“你第一次做爱不会觉得开心的，”这是她的第一个警告。“那会很尴尬，很难堪——相信我——还会很疼。”好吧，谢谢妈。
And the survey done by Sex, Etc. showed that sex ed classes in schools are all over the place right now. Here's Natasha, who wrote the survey questions.
《Sex, Etc.》做的调查显示，学校的性教育课目前乱象丛生。这是写调查问题的娜塔莎。
Some people didn't even have sex ed. They were like, I don't have sex ed. Some people were like, I wish I had sex ed, but I don't. Some people talked about how their teacher just talked about abstinence only. They didn't really answer any of their questions. Some people said they had really good teachers. But most of the people that really replied said that they really weren't satisfied with their sex ed.
有些人甚至没有上过性教育课。他们说，我没上过。有些人说，我希望有，但我没有。有些人谈到老师只谈禁欲。他们真的没有回答任何问题。有些人说他们有很好的老师。但大多数回应的人都说他们对性教育课很不满意。
I was actually the one. I raised my hand in class and I said, but how does the sperm get to the vagina? And I guess it wasn't in the material. They're not supposed to talk about it. So they were just like-- they just didn't talk to us about it.
其实我就是那个例子。我在课上举手说，但是精子怎么进入阴道？我觉得这不在教材里。他们不应该谈论这个。所以他们只是……他们干脆就不谈。
It's confusing. You don't know what that means. When I was younger, I thought sex was just sort of like people rubbing up against each other. Because you can see on TV shows or movies, you see that, but you don't actually see. So you're like, OK, they rub against each other, but then how does that little fish get inside her body? And I would think of it as like a little fish, because you see it on the movie. And so how does it get inside her body? It's so confusing and vague.
这很让人困惑。你不知道那是什么意思。我年轻时，以为性就是人们相互摩擦。因为你在电视节目或电影里能看到那个，但你其实看不到细节。所以你会想，好的，他们相互摩擦，但那条小鱼怎么进入她身体？我会把它想成一条小鱼，因为在电影里看到了。那它怎么进入她身体？太令人困惑和模糊了。
Most of the stuff, honestly, most of the things I learned about sex are probably from watching pornography, because there's a lot there. You might as well be taking notes, because it's very up close and personal. And they're not trying to censor themselves. So they can show anything they want. And you learn. Because they're wearing condoms most of the time.
老实说，大多数东西，我关于性的知识可能大部分来自看色情片，因为那上面很多。你可能都在做笔记，因为这非常近距离而且私密。他们不会试图审查自己。所以他们可以展示任何他们想展示的东西。你学到了。因为大多数时候他们都戴着避孕套。
Porn kind of shows you exactly what happens. Like you'll see it on TV, and they're just kind of rubbing together under the covers. But porn is like there. Like it zooms in, and all kinds of stuff. So it really shows you what actually happens.
色情片展示了具体发生了什么。就像你在电视上看到的，他们只是在被子下摩擦。但色情片不一样。它会放大，等等。所以它真的展示了实际发生了什么。
The most confusing thing about talking to these kids is to find out that there are so many ways for parents to mess this up. Kids complain when parents don't approach them to talk about sex. They also complain that parents bring it up out of the blue, when they're unprepared, and trap them. They complain that parents are usually vague, though of course when they want details, they emphatically do not want to hear first person accounts of their parents' sex lives. One kid in the survey wrote, "I was in fifth grade at the time when my parents started the sex talk with, 'The first time your father and I had intercourse--' I didn't need the details."
与这些孩子交谈中最令人困惑的发现是，父母搞砸这件事的方法有太多种了。孩子抱怨父母不主动谈性。也抱怨父母在完全没准备好的情况下冷不丁提起，把他们困住。他们抱怨父母通常含糊其辞，当然当他们想要细节时，又绝对不想听父母第一视角的性生活经历。调查中一个孩子写道：“我读五年级时，父母用‘你父亲和我第一次发生性关系时……’开启了性话题。我才不需要细节。”
I don't want to know nothing. I don't want to know about the backseat. I don't want to know about when they had drive-in movie theaters. I don't want to know about nothing. I just don't want to know. Like my father-- no, my father-- says stuff to me like that. "Yeah, me and your mother went to the hotel, and we--" I don't want to know.
我什么都不想知道。我不想知道后座的事情。我不想知道他们去汽车影院时的事情。我什么都不想知道。我就是不想知道。像我父亲——不，我父亲——会跟我说那种话。“是啊，我和你妈去了旅馆，然后我们……”我不想知道。
But there's a surprising lack of consensus among these seven teenagers, seven kids who write about this, and have thought about this a lot, about how parents should go about talking sex with their own kids. Two of the editors said that their parents are so uncomfortable with the subject, they preferred not to talk to them about it. The two editors who had the easiest time talking about sex with their own parents have the kind of incredibly close relationships with their parents where they can talk about anything. So it's hard to draw any kind of lesson from their experience, other than the not very helpful, have a great relationship with your kid.
但这七个青少年，七个对此有想法并深入思考过的孩子，在父母应该如何与自己的孩子谈论性这个问题上，竟然缺乏共识。两名编辑说他们的父母对这个话题太别扭了，他们宁愿不谈。那两个与父母谈性最轻松的编辑，是因为他们与父母之间有着极其亲密的关系，什么都能聊。所以很难从他们的经验中得出任何有用的教训，除了那条很不实用的建议：和你的孩子建立良好的关系。
For parents who are not spectacularly close with their own teenagers-- which is to say, most parents-- there was agreement about two things. One, parents need to understand that teenagers do not have the facts. They're not getting the facts in school, probably. And they need some basic information from books, or websites, or teachers, or wherever. And number two, no matter how hard it is, parents should at least try to talk to them. Again here's Natasha.
对于那些与子女并没有特别亲近——也就是说，大多数父母——在两点上达成了一致。第一，父母需要理解青少年并没有事实真相。他们在学校大概没得到真相。他们需要从书籍、网站、老师或其他任何地方获取基础信息。第二，无论多难，父母至少应该尝试去谈。再次请出娜塔莎。
I know you're getting older. Sex may become an issue, or sex is a part of growing up. It's natural. If you have questions--
我知道你在长大。性可能会成为一个问题，或者性是成长的一部分。这是自然的。如果你有问题——
Even as you're saying this, it's so awkward. I feel so awkward hearing you say this. This sounds terrible.
就算你这么说，还是很尴尬。我听到你这么说觉得太尴尬了。这听起来太糟糕了。
[LAUGHTER] Basically--
[笑声] 基本上——
You're terrible at this.
你真不擅长这个。
I did a good job on my brother. I did a really good job on him. But I actually locked my little brother in my room with me, because I wasn't sure if my mom was going to do it or not. So I was like, somebody has to do it.
我对我弟弟做得很成功。我对他做得很成功。但我实际上把我弟弟锁在房间里，因为我不确定我妈会不会去做。所以我想，总得有人去做。
How old was he?
他多大了？
He was 13. I just showed him diagrams. I showed him the picture. So I gave him condoms and everything. I was like, here, take these. If you're going to do it, use these. I said, this is what happens when you do this. This is what happens when you do that. If you want to do this, you should do this. But if I had my own child, and I watched them grow up from a baby into this adult, then yeah, it would definitely be difficult, just because of the age difference, because of--
他13岁。我只是给他看了图示。我给他看了图片。给了他避孕套和所有东西。我说，给你，拿着。如果你非要做，就用这些。我说，做这个时会发生这种事。做那个时会发生那种事。如果你想做这个，你就该这样做。但如果我有自己的孩子，我看着他们从婴儿长成大人，那当然会很困难，就因为年龄差异，因为……
No, I understand that. I understand. It's just interesting that you have in your head, oh someday I'm going to be older. And then I'm not going to be able to talk to my kid either.
不，我理解。我理解。只是很有趣，你脑子里会想，哦，有一天我会变老。然后我也无法跟我的孩子沟通了。
Yeah, it's just kind of the norm. You kind of assume that when you get older, you're not going to be able to talk to your kids about sex. I'm comfortable with my brother. I can talk to him about it. But if it's my child, it would just be awkward.
是的，这就是常态。你会默认当你变老，就无法和孩子谈性。我跟我弟弟很自在。我可以跟他谈。但如果是我自己的孩子，那会很尴尬。
Were there certain things that you said to your brother, and the way you said them, that it's impossible to imagine your mother or father saying to you?
有没有什么话是你跟你弟弟说的方式，让你觉得你的父母不可能那样对你说的？
Definitely. Like I told my brother, wrap it before you tap it. That kind of thing. I wouln't expect for my mother to say that to me. It's really hard for your parents to be that blunt with you, because it's a really, really awkward situation. It's just really awkward. That's really what it is. Awkward. I think it's really hard for parents. But they've just got to suck it up. They've done a lot of hard things in their life. Talking about sex shouldn't be one of the hardest things they've ever done, so.
绝对有。比如我告诉弟弟，做了再带套。那种话。我指望不了我妈对我那样说。父母很难对你那么直白，因为这确实是一个非常非常尴尬的情况。真的很尴尬。就是这样。尴尬。我觉得这对父母来说很难。但他们必须挺过去。他们这辈子经历过很多难事。谈性不该是他们经历过最难的事儿。
It can be very hard for parents, especially when their kids don't just come to them to talk about sex, but let them know that they're doing things that the parents don't necessarily approve of. This woman sent in an essay to us that she had written about what is happening in her family, between her and one of her daughters. It's so frank about what's happening, as you'll hear, that we have changed everybody's names and, in fact, had somebody else read it on the air. Here it is.
这对父母来说可能非常难，尤其是当孩子不主动来找他们谈性，反而让他们知道自己在做父母未必赞同的事情时。这位女士发了一篇她写的散文给我们，关于她家里发生的事情，她和其中一个女儿之间。就像你即将听到的那样，内容非常坦诚，我们更改了所有人的名字，实际上，请了别人在广播里朗读。就是这个。
I sit alone at my kitchen table, nibbling on a stale oatmeal cookie. It's midnight, and I'm hoping that the dose of tryptophan I had washed down with a glass of cold milk will kick in soon, so I can sleep. I'm a bundle of nerves because my 16 year old daughter just told me she lost her virginity the night before.
我独自坐在餐桌旁，吃着一块陈年的燕麦饼干。已经是午夜了，我希望我刚就着一杯冷牛奶喝下的色氨酸能快点起效，这样我就能睡觉。我紧张得要死，因为我16岁的女儿刚才告诉我她昨晚失去了童贞。
When Didi delivered the news tonight, I had nothing to say, which surprised me, because I'd always thought this is what I wanted with my three daughters, an open relationship. I hadn't thought through what that means. Which is that they talk, and then I talk. In this case, Didi talked. And I could only come up with a bland admonition. Don't sleep around, I said dryly.
当迪迪今晚带来这个消息时，我竟然无话可说，这让我很惊讶，因为我一直认为这就是我想要的——和我三个女儿拥有开放的关系。我没仔细想过那意味着什么。意思就是她们说，然后我说。在这种情况下，迪迪说了。我却只能挤出一句苍白的告诫。别乱搞，我干巴巴地说道。
I am not the mother I had hoped to be. My three girls are not the daughters I thought they'd be. I didn't think any of the girls would be valedictorians. But I expected my oldest daughter to graduate with something higher than a 1.8 GPA. My middle daughter didn't even do that well. She dropped out of high school. I never dreamed I would raise a smoker. And yet, my baby, Didi, carries a pack of Camels in her purse.
我不是我所希望成为的那种母亲。我的三个女孩也不是我想象中的女儿。我没想过她们任何一个能成为告别演说的代表。但我原以为我的大女儿毕业时GPA至少能比1.8高。我的二女儿表现得甚至更糟。她从高中退学了。我从没想过我会养出一个烟鬼。然而，我的小宝贝，迪迪，包里随时带着一盒骆驼香烟。
I squint at a magazine in the dim kitchen light, but can't concentrate. I take a couple of valerian capsules-- tryptophan is not enough tonight-- and go back to bed. Tomorrow, I'll make a doctor's appointment for Didi to get birth control.
我在昏暗的厨房光线下眯着眼看杂志，却无法集中注意力。我吃了两颗缬草胶囊——今晚光靠色氨酸不够了——然后回床上了。明天，我要给迪迪预约医生去搞避孕措施。
When I call the clinic to make an appointment for Didi, the receptionist's tone turns icy when I explain what I want. She says, neither the doctor nor the nurse practitioner has any openings until May. It's March. I can feel her disapproval through the phone. She seems to be implying that I am encouraging my daughter to have sex by arranging birth control for her, that I should encourage-- no, demand-- abstinence from Didi.
当我打电话给诊所帮迪迪预约时，我解释了我的要求，前台的语气立刻变得冰冷。她说，医生和执业护士到五月之前都没有档期。现在是三月。我能感受到电话那头她的不屑。她似乎在暗示，我是在通过为女儿安排避孕来鼓励她发生性关系，我应该鼓励——不，要求——迪迪禁欲。
I picture a good mother saying to her daughter, you're too young to have sex. Don't do it again until you're mature enough for a committed relationship, or better yet, until you're married. And the good daughter nods dutifully in agreement, and says, OK, Mom. It was fun, but you're right. We won't have sex anymore.
我想象着一位好母亲会对女儿说，你还太小，不能发生性关系。在你足够成熟能进行一段认真关系之前，或者更好，在结婚之前，别再做了。然后那个好女儿顺从地点头表示同意，说，好的，妈妈。那很有趣，但你说得对。我们再也不做爱了。
Didi and I occupy an alternate universe. In the afternoon, she returns home from school with a single red rose. It's from Jack, she says. You know, because. Yeah, I know, I say. Then she pulls from her purse something else that Jack brought her. A morning after pill. I thought you said he pulled out, I scream. Not that I think this is a reliable method, but it had provided me with a shred of hope that Didi's first time wouldn't result in a pregnancy. No, I, I just said that so you wouldn't worry, she said.
迪迪和我在一个平行的宇宙里。下午，她从学校回来，带着一朵红玫瑰。她说，这是杰克送的。你知道的，因为……是啊，我知道，我说。然后她从包里掏出杰克带给她的另一样东西。一颗事后避孕药。我尖叫道，我以为你说他中途拔出来了！并不是说我认为这是一个可靠的方法，但它曾带给我一丝希望，迪迪的第一次不会导致怀孕。她说，不，我，我只是那样说，好让你不担心。我把那颗药放回包里。我说，别撒谎。我最受不了你撒谎。谎言绝没好下场。她把药放回包里时继续说，他真的很担心。所以他才那么做。我说，我也很担心。我会帮你的。我意识到五月等得太久了。我再次给医生的办公室打电话。我恳求道，难道不能快点吗？一位更乐于助人的前台说可以。在失去童贞不到一周后，迪迪就吃上了避孕药。
Don't lie, I say. I can't stand it when you lie. Nothing ever good comes from a lie. He was really concerned. That's why he did that, she continues as she returns the pill to her purse. I'm concerned too, I say. I would have helped you. I realize May is too long to wait. I phone the doctor's office again. I plead, can't they speed this up somehow? A much more accommodating receptionist says they can. Less than a week after losing her virginity, Didi is on the pill.
（注：原文此处有重复，翻译保持原意）
Two weeks later, we're in Chicago. It's spring break, and Didi has persuaded me to take the train down for some shopping. Jack and a group of their friends are here. And Didi plans to meet up with them to go to a concert out in the suburbs later tonight. Is it OK, she asks, if it's really late tonight after the concert-- I mean, it shouldn't be. And Jack could stay with his friends in the suburbs. But then I might have to come back by myself, because I don't know if Lisa and Rachel are going. And they're staying at another hotel anyway. And I was wondering because of that, because I don't really want to come back by myself, and Jack doesn't really know his way back, if he just drops me off, I was wondering if it might be OK if he stays in our room?
两周后，我们在芝加哥。正是春假，迪迪说服我乘火车过来购物。杰克和他们的一群朋友也在这里。迪迪打算今晚晚些时候去郊区找他们参加音乐会。她问，我可以吗，如果今晚音乐会后真的很晚了——我的意思是，不应该这样。杰克可以和他在郊区的朋友待在一起。但我可能得自己回去，因为我不知道丽莎和瑞秋是不是要去。反正她们住在另一家旅馆。我想着，因为那个，因为我真不想自己回去，而且杰克不知道回来的路，如果他只是送我回来，我在想让他待在我们的房间里是不是可以？
We're having lunch in an Indian restaurant. And between Didi's tortured syntax and my rice pudding, it takes me a few seconds to fully understand what my teenage daughter is asking me. Um, I don't know, I say. I prefer you come back. And I don't want you to travel by yourself at night. But, um, I don't know.
我们在一家印度餐厅吃午饭。在迪迪磕磕绊绊的语法和我对米布丁的消灭中，我花了点时间才完全理解我青春期女儿在问什么。我说，嗯，我不知道。我希望你回来。而且我不想你晚上自己旅行。但是，嗯，我不知道。
Sometime after midnight, I hear the hotel key card in the door. Groggy from a sleeping pill, I'm aware of whispers and movement in the double bed next to mine in the moments before I drift off. When I awake the next morning, they are tangled in the blankets, their heads nearly touching. Didi's mouth is parted a bit, as it often is in sleep, and Jack's stockinged feet protrude over the edge of the mattress.
午夜过后，我听到了旅馆门禁卡的声音。因为安眠药昏昏沉沉，在昏昏欲睡前，我意识到了隔壁双人床上的窃窃私语和动静。第二天早晨醒来时，他们缠在毯子里，头几乎碰在一起。迪迪的嘴微张，睡着时常这样，杰克的袜子脚伸出床垫边缘。
Two weeks earlier, I was on the verge of a panic attack because Didi and her boyfriend had had sex for the first time. And now we're all sleeping in the same room together? What am I doing? I'm the first to admit I don't have a clue. What I do know is that I can't recall ever looking as happy as my daughter looks right now. I feel a disquieting sense of envy for Didi.
两周前，我正处于恐慌症发作的边缘，因为迪迪和她男友第一次发生了性关系。而现在我们都睡在同一个房间里？我到底在干什么？我是第一个承认自己毫无头绪的人。我所知道的是，我记不起曾见过女儿像现在这样开心。我对迪迪有一种令人不安的嫉妒感。
My husband and I don't even share our queen size bed, and I prefer it that way. At 53, Rob is retired, and spends his days consuming vast quantities of beer and napping. He doesn't bother to shower, shave, get his hair cut. We go months without riding in the same vehicle. We do not exchange gifts, or cards even. Maybe it's best we don't do cards. It's hard to find one that says, even though I don't love you anymore, happy birthday anyway.
我和丈夫甚至不共用一张大床，而我更喜欢那样。53岁的罗伯退休了，整天喝大量的啤酒，睡午觉。他懒得洗澡、刮胡子、理发。我们可以几个月都不坐同一辆车。我们互不送礼，甚至不互送卡片。也许我们不送卡片更好。很难找到一张卡片上面写着：尽管我不再爱你，但还是祝你生日快乐。
A few weeks later, after we return from Chicago, I'm reading in bed on a summer night when I hear strange noises from Didi's room below. When I open her bedroom door, she's cutting the screen out of her side window. "What are you doing?" I ask. "My mom, I have got to go." She slams her cellphone shut. "Uh, um, well, Jack called. And he's with his friends. And um, they wanted to drive around and get drunk. But he doesn't want to. And his parents are mad at him. But they think he's spending the night with those guys. So he can't really go home. So I told him he could come here. But I didn't want to wake anybody up. So I figured he could come in the window?"
几周后，从芝加哥回来后，一个夏夜我正在床上看书，听到楼下迪迪房间里有奇怪的声音。我打开她卧室的门，她正把窗户的纱窗剪掉。“你在干什么？”我问。“妈，我必须走。”她挂断了手机。“呃，嗯，是这样，杰克打了电话。他和朋友们在一起。然后，嗯，他们想开车出去喝个烂醉。但他不想去。他父母生他的气。但他们以为他和那些人待在一起。所以他没法回家。所以我告诉他可以来这里。但我不想吵醒任何人。所以我琢磨他可以从窗户进来？”
"You ruined the screen." I wave my arms in exasperation. "Why didn't you just say something to me?" "But, um, can he come over? He could be here any minute." I sigh. He'd spent the night at the hotel. I know they're having sex somewhere. And Didi is on the pill, so I know she won't get pregnant. What's the harm? Making my daughter happy seems closer to right than protecting her virginity or reputation.
“你把纱窗弄坏了。”我愤慨地挥舞手臂。“为什么不直接跟我说？”“但是，嗯，他可以过来吗？他随时可能到。”我叹了口气。他已经在旅馆过夜了。我知道他们肯定在什么地方发生着性关系。迪迪在吃避孕药，所以我知道她不会怀孕。有什么坏处呢？让女儿开心似乎比保护她的童贞或名声更正确。
I know that I was raised to be chaste, to put off sex until marriage. And how did that turn out for me? I had sex atop dorm room bunks and secondhand sofas. Worried whether I'd be invited to stay the night, felt ashamed the next morning. I fawned over the bad boys. Now I'm tired and unhappy. Maybe there is another way.
我知道我从小受到的教育是贞洁，要把性行为推迟到婚后。结果如何呢？我在宿舍的铺位和二手沙发上做过爱。担心是否会被邀请过夜，第二天早晨感到羞耻。我曾迷恋坏男孩。现在我精疲力尽，不幸福。也许有另一条路。
OK, I say, listening for sounds of Rob fumbling around upstairs. But let him in the front door. Jack becomes a late night regular at our house. Even though they barely speak, the tension between Didi and her dad comes to a boil in the week since Jack first began spending the night. She says to me one day, "I can't stand it. Can't you leave him now?"
我听着楼上罗伯笨手笨脚的声音，说，好的。但让他走前门。杰克成了我们家深夜的常客。即使他们几乎不说话，自从杰克开始过夜以来，迪迪和她父亲之间的紧张关系在一周内达到了沸点。有一天她对我说道：“我受不了了。你现在不能离开他吗？”
Didi wants me to leave Rob, and buy a house near downtown so the three of us-- herself, Mandy, and I-- can get on with our lives. I can't tell her that I don't have the money, that I don't have the energy, that I am afraid of what will become of me, and her, and her sisters. A good mother wouldn't continue to live with a bad father. A good mother would never have married someone like Rob in the first place.
迪迪想让我离开罗伯，买一套靠近市区的房子，这样我们三个——她、曼迪和我——就能过上自己的生活。我没法告诉她我没钱，我没精力，我害怕我和她，还有她姐妹们未来会怎样。一位好母亲不会继续和一个坏父亲住在一起。一位好母亲绝不会嫁给像罗伯这样的人。
"I can't stand it here," Didi says, the tears still flowing. "I think I need to go back on anti-depressants." All of us, except Rob, the one who needs the most, has been on, or is on, anti-depressants. "Take a few of mine." I want to shout, "Snap out of it." "Oh Mom, I just have to get out of this house. Would you please, please let me stay at a hotel tonight with Jack? Please? I just need to get away."
“我在这里待不下去了，”迪迪说着，眼泪还在流。“我想我需要重新吃抗抑郁药。”我们所有人，除了罗伯——那个最需要吃药的人——都曾服用或正在服用抗抑郁药。“吃点我的。”我想大喊，“振作点。”“哦妈，我必须离开这个家。求求你，求求你让我今晚和杰克待在旅馆好吗？求求你？我必须远离这里。”
"A hotel costs a lot of money," I point out. "I mean, I'd like to go away too, but, I can't do that every time I want." "Just for tonight?" she asks. "Please. I just have to get out of here, away from him." She looks in the direction of the living room, where Rob lays on the couch, mouth agape. Of course, I want to help her. Indulge her. I understand her pain. But at the cost of $100 or more?
“旅馆要花很多钱，”我指出。“我的意思是，我也想离开，但是，我不能每次我想走就走。”“就今晚？”她问。“求求你。我必须离开这里，离开他。”她看向客厅的方向，罗伯正摊在沙发上，张着嘴。当然，我想帮她。纵容她。我理解她的痛苦。但代价是100美元或更多？
"You've spent more than that on hotels for Mandy," she says. "It's like, well, like therapy." It's true. I've spent a lot sending Mandy to anime conventions around the country, but they were for a purpose. Not just because she didn't want to sleep at home. And I know responsible mothers would not pay for a night at a hotel for their minor child, with a boyfriend no less. It's unseemly.
“你花在曼迪旅馆上的钱比那多多了，”她说。“那就像……嗯，就像治疗。”这是真的。我花了很多钱送曼迪去全国各地的动漫展，但那是有目的的。不是因为她不想在家睡觉。而且我知道负责任的母亲不会为未成年子女支付旅馆费，更何况还是带男友。这很不体面。
But somehow none of those reasons seem to matter. And I agree it could be therapeutic for Didi. I'm a believer in retreats and getaways to revitalize the spirit. And I know that Didi will be unrelenting until I finally say yes. I give in. "See if you can find a deal on hotwire.com," I say. She throws her arms around me. The tears have left damp tracks on her cheeks. "Thank you, thank you, thank you." And she rushes off to wheel and deal her way into a room at the Holiday Inn.
但不知何故，那些原因似乎都不重要。我同意这对迪迪可能有治疗作用。我信奉隐居和逃避可以焕发精神。我知道如果我不答应，迪迪会没完没了。我屈服了。“去Hotwire.com看看有没有优惠，”我说。她搂住我。泪水在她脸颊上留下了湿痕。“谢谢，谢谢，谢谢。”然后她冲出去，用她的方式搞定了一间假日酒店的房间。
Because she is 16, I have to check her in. When we leave the house, I call to Rob, who's still on the sofa, "Didi is staying with a friend tonight. I'm going to drop her off now." He doesn't have to know the details about this. Didi snags a room overlooking the indoor pool and courtyard. I stand on its balcony and watch the people dining in the tropical-themed restaurant. Families playing in the pool, adults soaking in the hot tub, everyone looks happy. I turn back to the room. Jack is at work and he'll be along later. Didi has invited one of her girlfriends over to go swimming. While we wait on her, both of us sprawl across the king sized bed.
因为她只有16岁，我必须帮她办理入住。离开家时，我对着还在沙发上的罗伯喊道，“迪迪今晚和朋友待在一起。我现在送她过去。”他不必要知道这件事的细节。迪迪订到了一个能俯瞰室内泳池和庭院的房间。我站在阳台上，看着人们在热带主题的餐厅用餐。家庭在游泳池里玩耍，成年人在热水浴缸里浸泡，每个人看起来都很开心。我转身回房。杰克在工作，待会会过来。迪迪邀请了一个女朋友过来游泳。我们等她的时候，我们俩都摊在特大号床上。
"Comfortable?" I ask and close my eyes. "Yeah, I'll say," she says. "Thanks for letting me do this, Mom." I understand why she wanted to come here. The windowless room is soothing and anonymous. The sliding glass doors face the courtyard, and artificial light spills into the room. From the pool below, there is the faint aroma of chlorine. I don't want to leave. I want to crawl under the covers for a long nap.
“舒服吗？”我问并闭上眼睛。“是啊，挺好，”她说。“谢谢你让我这么做，妈。”我理解她为什么想来这里。没有窗户的房间让人平静且隐蔽。滑动玻璃门对着庭院，人造光洒进房间。从下面的游泳池，传来淡淡的氯气味。我不想离开。我想爬进被子里睡个长觉。
Julie Snyder. Reading an essay sent in to us by a woman who lives in the Midwest.
朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。朗读一位住在中西部的女士发给我们的一篇散文。
[MUSIC - "TRUST YOUR CHILD" BY PATRIZIA & JIMMY]
[音乐 - Patrizia & Jimmy的《Trust Your Child》]
ACT 3, Use Your Words. Well we close today's show with this story from Dan Savage about how to talk to kids, and how his views on the subject have changed pretty radically, how he believes stuff now that he would have found repellent years ago. Here's Dan.
第三幕，用你的语言。好吧，我们今天以丹·萨维奇关于如何与孩子交谈的故事结束节目。他的观点发生了多么激进的改变，他现在相信了一些他在几年前会觉得令人反感的东西。请出丹。
In the fall of 1989, I was living in West Berlin and needed a job. The only one I could find was working as a substitute German teacher at a grade school on the US Army base. One day, this kid-- this little black haired, black eyed, black hearted boy-- started winding up my worst class, Berlin's fightin' fourth graders, taunting weaker kids, firing paper clips around the room with a rubber band, all the while shooting me looks that said, what are you going to do about it, you pathetic excuse for a German teacher?
1989年秋天，我住在西柏林，需要找份工作。我唯一能找到的就是在美国陆军基地的学校担任德语代课老师。有一天，那个孩子——那个黑头发、黑眼睛、心肠黑透的小男孩——开始折磨我最差的班级，柏林好斗的四年级生，嘲弄弱小的孩子，用橡皮筋把回形针射遍教室，同时用那种目光盯着我，仿佛在说，你打算怎么办，你这个卑微的德语老师？
I glared. I issued idle threats. I raised my voice. Nothing worked. I was on the verge of losing complete control of the classroom. So I got up, walked over to this kid's desk, and snatched the rubber band out of his hand. Then I leaned in close so only he could hear me and said, "Knock it the [BEEP] off, you little [BEEP]."
我怒目而视。我发出虚张声势的威胁。我提高嗓门。没用。我快要完全失去对教室的控制了。所以我站起来，走到那个孩子的桌前，从他手里夺过橡皮筋。然后凑近他，只有他能听见，说道：“把你的嘴闭上，你这小杂种。”
I said it with the most threateningly murderous tone I could affect. I wanted this kid to think me capable of anything. Anything. It worked, or seemed to. The kid was quiet for the rest of class. And I hoped that we had come to an understanding. Then I got summoned to the principal's office ten minutes into my next class. When I walked in, the black haired kid was standing by his desk. The principal asked me if I had used the f-word in front of this precious child, that I had told this child that he was a piece of s-word.
我用我所能表现出的最具威胁性的杀气说出这句话。我想让这孩子认为我什么都做得出来。任何事。这奏效了，或者看起来奏效了。那孩子在余下的课里很安静。我希望我们达成了某种默契。结果在下一节课开始十分钟后，我被叫到了校长办公室。我走进去时，那个黑头发的孩子正站在办公桌旁。校长问我是否在这个宝贵的孩子面前用了那个F开头的脏话，是否告诉这个孩子他是个烂玩意。
Mr. Savage, the principal said, interrupting me before I could answer, "I'm afraid this would be a firing offense, if it were true." I took in the look on the principal's face as I paused to consider my response. It wasn't an angry look. It was a do we understand each other look. I understood. He didn't want to fire me any more than I wanted to be fired. If the position of substitute German teacher was easier to fill, he wouldn't have hired me in the first place. I barely spoke the language.
萨维奇先生，校长打断我，没让我回答，“恐怕如果这是真的，这就是会被开除的行为。”我看着校长的脸，停顿了一下考虑回应。那不是生气的表情。那是那种“我们明白彼此吗”的眼神。我明白了。他并不想开除我，就像我并不想被开除一样。如果代课德语老师的职位容易填补，他一开始就不会雇我。我几乎不会说这门语言。
"No," I said. "It's not true." "He said it," the kid choked out. "He did!" The principal leaned back in his chair. "Or perhaps," the principal said, "it was all a misunderstanding." The principal had us shake hands and then dismissed us together. I wasn't fired. And, revealingly, the kid wasn't in any trouble. The boy shot me a look when we got into the hall. I knew I lied. He knew I lied. I knew he knew. And we both knew the principal knew.
“不，”我说。“那不是真的。”“他说过，”那孩子哽咽着。“他确实说了！”校长靠在椅背上。“或者也许，”校长说，“这一切都是误会。”校长让我们握手，然后把我们一起打发走了。我没被开除。而且，揭露真相的是，那孩子也没惹上麻烦。我们在走廊时，那男孩盯着我。我知道我撒谎了。他知道我撒谎了。我知道他知道。我们也都知道校长知道。
I felt terrible, honestly. For years later-- long after I forgot what little German I knew-- my mind would occasionally flash to the look on that boy's face. That kid was bad. But I proved to him that adults are worse. We swear, we lie, we abuse our authority. And for years, I had the decency to feel bad about the indecent thing I had done that day.
说实话，我感觉糟透了。多年后——在我忘记了我所知的那点儿可怜的德语很久之后——我的脑海里偶尔会闪过那男孩的表情。那孩子很坏。但我向他证明了大人更坏。我们骂人、撒谎、滥用职权。多年来，我一直有良心为那天所做的不光彩的事感到愧疚。
But now I don't feel bad about it. Yes, the lying was wrong, I guess. But telling him to knock it the [BEEP] off? He had it coming. And why do I feel this way? Because I have my own nine year old now. And I have gone Alec Baldwin on his ass many times.
但现在我不为此感到愧疚了。是的，撒谎是错的，我想。但叫他把嘴闭上？他活该。为什么我有这种感觉？因为我现在有自己的九岁孩子了。而且我已经无数次像亚历克·鲍德温（Alec Baldwin）那样对他发火了。
I want to tell you something, OK? And I want to leave a message for you right now. You have insulted me for the last time.
我想告诉你一件事，好吗？我现在要给你留个口信。你最后一次羞辱我了。
In fact, when the phone message the actor left for his daughter was made public, I thought, what's the big deal? Apparently his daughter missed some scheduled phone calls with him.
事实上，当那位演员留给女儿的语音留言被公开时，我想，大惊小怪什么？显然他的女儿错过了一些预定的通话。
You have insulted me. You don't have the brains, or the decency as a human being. I don't give a damn that you're 12 years old, or 11 years old, or that you're a child, or that your mother is a thoughtless pain in the ass who doesn't care about what you do, as far as I'm concerned. You have humiliated me for the last time with this phone. And when I come out there next week, I'm going to fly out there for the day just to straighten you out on this issue. I'm going to let you know just how disappointed in you I am.
你羞辱了我。你根本没有脑子，也没有身为人类的体面。我一点也不在乎你只有12岁，还是11岁，或者你是个孩子，或者你那个妈是个没心没肺的混蛋，完全不关心你的所作所为。你这是最后一次通过电话羞辱我了。等我下周过去，我会专门飞去那儿一天，就为了解决这个问题。我要让你知道我对此有多失望。
Everyone seemed to think that Baldwin losing his temper like that-- and he did lose his temper-- was grounds for denying him visitation rights. Baldwin hit the public contrition circuit. People were talking about whether or not his career would survive. But I wasn't the only one out there that couldn't understand what all the fuss was about. A lot of people listened to the Baldwin tape and came to the same conclusion I had. No. Big. Deal. Who were these people? Parents. Parents like me.
每个人似乎都认为鲍德温那样发火——他确实发火了——是剥夺他探视权的理由。鲍德温踏上了公众忏悔之旅。人们在讨论他的职业生涯是否还能继续。但并不是只有我一个人无法理解这有什么大不了的。很多人听了鲍德温的录音后，得出了和我一样的结论。没。什。么。大。不。了。的。这些人是谁？父母。像我一样的父母。
We didn't speak up then because we were afraid. We were cowards, thoughtless cowards, without the brains or the decency of human beings. Only after the Baldwin scandal blew over, did we parents slowly and carefully begin to check in with each other and confide in each other. That wasn't so bad, right? I've said worse things, haven't you? I'm sorry we weren't there for you, Alec.
我们当时没敢说话，因为我们害怕。我们是懦夫，没心没肺的懦夫，没有脑子，也没有作为人类的体面。直到鲍德温丑闻平息后，我们这些父母才慢慢小心翼翼地互通声气，倾诉心声。那没什么大不了的，对吧？我说过比这更难听的话，你没说过吗？亚历克，很抱歉当时没站在你这边。
So you better be ready Friday, the 20th, to meet with me. So I'm going to let you know just how I feel about what a rude little pig you really are. You are a rude, thoughtless little pig.
所以你最好准备好周五，20号，跟我见面。我要让你知道，对于你这个没礼貌的小混蛋，我的真实感受。你是个粗鲁、没心没肺的小混蛋。
Have you talked to your kids like that?
你跟你的孩子那样说过话吗？
Oh yes, I have. Yeah. I yell all the time at my kids.
哦，是的，我说过。是啊。我总是对我孩子大吼大叫。
John is a stay at home dad with three boys and a girl. My son, DJ, plays with John's kids. I caught John on the phone while his younger children were napping.
约翰是个全职爸爸，有三个儿子一个女儿。我儿子DJ和约翰的孩子们一起玩。我在他小孩子午睡时给约翰打了电话。
What was your reaction when you heard the Alec Baldwin tape?
听到亚历克·鲍德温录音时，你的反应是什么？
Just what he actually said, out of context, seems incredibly benign. It seems like a typical tirade by a typical parent.
仅就他所说的话，脱离上下文来看，似乎非常无害。这看起来像是普通家长发出的典型长篇大论。
I talked to other parents, but they all said the same thing. They've said worse. They've lost it. Someone told me recently about one father-- a loving father, a good father-- who told his son, "I could kill you, and make another one, just like you."
我和其他家长谈过，他们都说了同样的话。他们说过更难听的。他们失控过。有人最近告诉我，一位父亲——一位慈爱的父亲，好父亲——对儿子说：“我真想杀掉你，再生一个，就像你这样。”
Alissa is the mother of two kids. A son, and a daughter the same age as Alec Baldwin's daughter. And please note my technique here. I draw the interview subject out by refusing to let her get a word in edgewise.
阿丽莎（Alissa）是两个孩子的妈妈。一个儿子，和一个与亚历克·鲍德温女儿同龄的女儿。请注意我这里的技巧。我通过拒绝让她插话来引导访谈对象。
Because when I heard that, I thought of all the times I've-- you know, we live in a two-story house. I thought of all the times I have barked up the stairs, "Don't make me come up there." Which sounds like, if I come up there, I'm going to throw you through a wall. And I want it to sound like that, a little bit. Like I, as a father, try to affect that tone, because it's kind of all I got. You can't hit him.
因为当我听到那个时，我想起所有我曾经……你知道，我们住在两层楼的房子里。我想起所有我对着楼梯大吼“别逼我上来”的时刻。那听起来像是，如果我上去，我就要把你甩在墙上。而且我确实想让它听起来像那样，一点点。就像我作为父亲，试图表现出那种语气，因为那几乎是我唯一拥有的武器。你不能打他。
Well, absolutely.
嗯，当然。
You really can't hit him.
你真的不能打他。
No. No, you can't hit them. It's not fair. It's not a fair fight.
不。不，你不能打他们。这不公平。这并不是一场公平的战斗。
And so sometimes I feel trapped, like the only way I can communicate my intense displeasure, and also, to my kid, how far he's pushed it, and that he might not want to push it that far with me, or other adults, or strangers on the street, is by sounding like I'm going to kill him. Physically, like I'm going to take his little neck in my hands and choke the life out of him. And so I feel like, oh my God, if somebody was walking down the street, and they heard the tone of my voice, and what I just said, they'd call the police.
所以有时候我觉得被困住了，好像我唯一能传达我强烈不满的方式——同时也是对孩子传达他做得太过分了，他可能不想再和我、或其他大人或路上的陌生人那样过分——就是听起来像是我要杀了他。身体上的，就像我要用双手掐住他小小的脖子，夺走他的生命一样。所以我心想，天哪，如果有人走在街上，听到了我的语气，听到了我刚才说的话，他们会报警的。
Of course. Absolutely. Well you know, I have had my children, when they were smaller, behave so badly at the playground. I was so angry at them. They were walking ahead of me, going home down the sidewalk. And I was walking behind them, giving them the finger behind their heads. And I'm sure people looked at me and thought, oh my God, take that woman's children away.
当然。绝对。嗯，你知道，当我的孩子还小的时候，他们在操场上的行为太糟糕了。我当时对他们太生气了。他们走在我前面，在人行道上回家。我走在他们后面，在他们头后比中指。我敢肯定人们看着我想，天哪，快把那个女人的孩子带走。
And I do feel like really yelling can be really cathartic. And you know what? It scares the crap out of them. When I yell at my kids-- which I don't do that much-- their eyes get enormous. They can tell how furious you are. My children have said to me, you have no idea how terrifying you are when you're angry. You're so much scarier than Daddy. And I thought well, you know what? Good, good. I've cultivated that.
我觉得大吼大叫真的能起到宣泄作用。而且你知道吗？那真的会把他们吓坏。当我对我孩子吼叫时——我其实吼得没那么多——他们的眼睛睁得巨大。他们看得出你有多愤怒。我的孩子们对我说过，你不知道你生气时有多吓人。你比爸爸可怕多了。我想，好吧，你知道吗？好，好。我培养出来的。
But I feel-- you know, listening to the tape, listening to Alec Baldwin, thinking about the times I've blown up in a similar way at my kid, I feel like, please don't take this away from me. Because he has to understand that there are limits, that you can push someone too far. And he has to learn that. And if I can teach him that just through volume, maybe he won't get beat up by a cop one day.
但我感觉……你知道，听那录音，听亚历克·鲍德温，想起我曾以同样方式对孩子爆发过的时候，我感觉，请别剥夺我这点权利。因为他必须明白是有底线的，你不能把一个人逼得太急。他必须学会这个。如果我只能通过音量来教会他，也许有一天他不会被警察揍一顿。
I believe that. I feel that way all the time, especially with my son.
我相信那一点。我一直都有这种感觉，尤其是对我儿子。
My impression of kids-- having been a parent, lo, these ten years now-- is that kids are sociopaths until you beat it out of them. Metaphorically, beat it out of them. All children start out as sociopaths. They all have to be civilized, as you said. And the only tool we have to do that with is language.
作为一个父母，这十年来的感触——我的印象是，孩子在没被你教训之前都是社会病态者。隐喻地，教训他们。所有孩子一开始都是社会病态者。他们都必须被文明化，正如你所说。而我们用来达到这一目的的唯一工具就是语言。
Yeah. Or taking things away from them. Without that, without really giving them real limits, you can't expect them to behave. How are they supposed to know what to do? They're like little aliens dropped here, naked, no money, nothing.
是啊。或者剥夺他们的东西。如果没有这个，如果不给他们真正的界限，你就不能指望他们表现好。他们怎么可能知道该怎么做？他们就像被丢到这儿的小外星人，赤身裸体，没钱，什么都没有。
If anything, with the removal of violence from the parenting arsenal, we've had to ramp up the screaming, and yelling, and profanity. It soaks up the energy and anger that might otherwise have gone into a clean, quick, smack. My son, DJ, turned nine last March. He just started the fourth grade. He can be a handful. And every once in a while his teacher has to reign him in.
如果说有什么变化，那就是随着育儿手段中暴力的移除，我们不得不加大尖叫、吼叫和讲粗口的力度。它吸收了那些本可能转化为干净利落一巴掌的能量和愤怒。我儿子DJ去年三月满九岁。他刚开始上四年级。他是个麻烦制造者。偶尔他的老师不得不约束他。
I don't expect that DJ's fourth grade teacher would ever swear at him the way I swore at that kid in Berlin. I was an inexperienced, untrained substitute. She's a pro. But knowing what I know now about kids, if DJ's teacher ever reaches the breaking point, if she ever leans in close and whispers, "Knock it the [BEEP] off," just loud enough for DJ to hear, I'd back her up. Because however bad he can be, DJ needs to understand that she, that all adults, can be much, much worse.
我不指望DJ的四年级老师会像我在柏林骂那个孩子那样对他讲脏话。我当时是个没经验、没受过训练的代课老师。她是专业人员。但以我对孩子的了解，如果DJ的老师真的到了崩溃边缘，如果她凑近他耳边轻声说：“把你的嘴闭上”，声音大到刚好能让DJ听见，我会支持她。因为无论他有多坏，DJ都需要明白，她——所有成年人——可能会比他坏得多。
Dan Savage is the author of several books and host of the fantastically enjoyable Savage Love podcasts, which you can find on the internet with a Google search, Savage Love podcast. Or go to the iTunes store.
丹·萨维奇是几本书的作者，也是令人愉快得不可思议的《Savage Love》播客的主持人，你可以通过在谷歌搜索“Savage Love podcast”找到它。或者去iTunes商店。
OK, they rub up against each other, but then how does that little fish get inside her body? And I would think of it as a little fish, because you see it on the movie. And so how does it get inside her body? You know, it's just so confusing and vague.
好的，他们相互摩擦，但那条小鱼怎么进入她身体？我会把它想成一条小鱼，因为电影里看到了。那它怎么进入她身体？你知道，太令人困惑和模糊了。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week, with more stories of This American life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。下周回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际台。